foreign
's text messages and emails and videos
are all out there on the internet for
the world to see and that is a pretty
major invasion of privacy we will
concede that how would you like your
text messages to get out there in public
on the other hand they probably wouldn't
be quite as interesting as Hunter
Biden's and on balance we're glad to see
them because we're learning a lot about
the Biden families business arrangements
with China and they are extensive but
we're also learning about what the Biden
family is like and boy are they
repulsive we learned among other things
what Hunter Biden thinks of the family
matriarch and that would of course be
America's doctor Dr Jill now the sun is
reporting that in one text message
Hunter Biden once described his
stepmother that would be the first lady
of the United States as we're quoting
now a vindictive [ __ ] he also called
her the bad word which we can't use on
TV but it's the bad one when you can't
use even at home use that word
but what about vindictive [ __ ] is that
true well we did a little research and
it turns out yeah it's true she's a
vindictive morning now we know she's a
[ __ ] because we read her doctoral
thesis and that proves among other
things that she can't do simple math and
if you don't believe that here's one
extra and we're quoting three quarters
of the class will be Caucasian one
quarter of the class will be
African-American one seat will hold a
Latino and the remaining seats will be
filled with students of Asian descent or
non-resident aliens
how many percentage points is that now
later on in the thesis it's a doctoral
thesis why she's Dr Jill she
miscalculates private and public sector
School enrollment by more than let's see
200 percentage points
now you might be tempted to dismiss all
of that maybe she wrote her thesis in 10
minutes of the subway knowing that no
one at the University of Delaware would
dare correct it and of course they
didn't and that would explain the
hundreds of typos in her thesis
but you don't need to believe for thesis
to know that Dr Jill is in fact in the
words of Hunter Biden himself her son a
[ __ ] because we have videos of her
speaking
here was Dr Jill yesterday at something
called the lat tinks inclusion luncheon
in San Antonio Texas
oh help build this organization with the
understanding that the diversity of this
community as distinct as of the Bronx as
beautiful as the blossoms of Miami and
it is
[Music]
[Applause]
Mercy
yes I'm not patronizing you latinx
people but you're all tacos
stop tacos that's what the first lady
said now the National Association of
Hispanic journalists which presumably
supports the bite Administration decided
they had to explain some things very
slowly to Dr Jill among others they said
this quote using breakfast tacos to try
and demonstrate the uniqueness of
Latinos demonstrates a lack of cultural
knowledge we are not tacos
tacos okay
so uh Jill Biden realized well maybe we
shouldn't call them tacos so her Press
Secretary of publicist put out a
statement doing a little damage control
quote the first lady apologizes that her
words conveyed anything but pure
admiration and love for the Latino
Community wait a second Jill button Dr
Jill the Latino Community what happened
to the lactinks community was that the
whole point of the luncheon to tell
Latinos that actually they're lat tanks
degender your language sexist Latinos
well the truth is for a long time
connecting with the lactinx community
has trained every ounce of intellect
that Jill Biden has to offer which is
limited as we noted here was Jill Biden
a year ago speaking to union workers in
California this is one of the greatest
moments ever caught on camera so pause
turn the volume up on your set and enjoy
anything is possible so say it with me
yeah
she say Padres Padres or something Cesar
Chavez used to say si say Palace you
couldn't speak Spanish either don't you
worry so Dr Joseph [ __ ] Hunter Biden
was absolutely right but was she
vindictive too that's the outstanding
question hunter called her an addictive
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes vindictive Jerry's still
out well now
we know a few days ago Jill Biden wrote
on Twitter that Women quote have the
right to make our own decisions about
our bodies of course not with the vax
but with abortion So reading this
retired lieutenant general Gary valeski
a former Army spokesman who mentors
soldiers responded this way quote glad
to see you finally know what a woman is
well guess what happened to General
valeski he got suspended now he's being
investigated by the U.S army which has
no problem with China but they're very
concerned that someone might criticize
Dr Jill
so Hunter Biden was right and we're just
going to say it out loud Hunter Biden
was right about Dr Jill
vindictive [ __ ]
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight